تعمل الدعايه بشكل افضل عندما يكون من يتم
التلاعب بهم واثقين من انهم يتصرفون بمحض
ارادتهم هذه عباره منسوبه لوزير
البروباغندا في الحكومه النازيه جوزيف
جوبلز ويبدو ان هذا ما تقوم به اجهزه
الدعايه الروسيه التي تنشر بين الفينه
والاخرى مثل هذا المقطع الذي يحض الشباب
على التطوع للقتال في الجبهات الاوكرانيه
يظهر في نهايه التسجيل كيف استفاد هذا
المقاتل من انضمامه للجيش الروسي بشرائه
سياره اساليب اخرى تتبعها السلطات الروسيه
لتشجيع الشباب على الانخراط في الحياه
العسكريه
بتذكيرهم بابطال الحكمه السفيه
وتعتبر هذه وسيله تقليديه
باستغلال فخر الشعب الروسي بالتاريخ
السوداني
المقاطع المسجله في اوكرانيا التي تظهر
فيها وحدات عسكريه روسيه تقوم بعمليات
خاصه واخرى تتجهز لقصف مواقع اوكرانيه
تنتشر في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الروسيه
كتلوجرام لجذب محبي الحياه العسكريه
القنوات الروسيه تلعب دورا رئيسيا في
ترسانه الكرملين للبروباغندا فهي تستضيف
ضيوفا في برامج حواريه
يتحدثون عن تمديد فتره الخدمه العسكريه
وتبث مقطوعات غنائيه عن الصواريخ
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه
لبث الشعور بالفخر بالقوات المسلحه
الروسيه وطمئنه الجبهه الداخليه التي
ابتدت تتممل من الحرب
[موسيقى]
من خدمه للوطن ومنافع ماديه
تصدم بواقع الهزائم الروسيه في اوكرانيا
وحاله الاسر التي يتعرض لها الجنود الروس